Hi I'm Geoff Donaker. I live here in the Bay
Area, California Bay area and I have red-green color blindness.
>> Okay, so red-green color blindness, we, you know, just sort of
heard about that for the first time. And in the course and
we're learning a bit more about the inheritance patterns. What is red
green color blindness? What does it mean to be red green color blind?
>> Well to me what it means is that I often mix
up colors that have red in them. And so in particular I
mix up reds and browns and sometimes browns and greens because I'm not
seeing the red correctly in those. Sometimes it can even show up in the
form of blues and purples. I'm sort of seeing them all at about
the same. And in fact you know they may look different to other people.
>> So, would it be accurate in saying. Just, they kind of
look like darker colors or is it something about the shade, maybe?
>> I'm not really sure. I think that the way
to think about it you know, for me is that sometimes
what you may be seeing as, as the red
in a particular orange for instance. To me I'm
not seeing the red the same way you are.
because I'm seeing it maybe like a dark yellow. and
so, I still, certainly see the world in a
vibrant colorful way and it's so like black and white
or anything like that. I just see it differently
than everybody else who doesn't see it in red-green color.
>> It's such a great like literal and
metaphorical statement. I think a lot of people do
go through life thinking you know the
assumption, this is the color vision, this is
the vision I have. But not everybody
literally sees the world in the same spectrum.
>> That's right.
>> what when did you first eh, know that you had red green color blindness?
>> You know I don't really remember. It was when
I was a really young child, my uncle had been red
green colorblind. And then actually my mom's uncle as well
so I think I inherited it from her side. And so
when I was a little kid she recognized that I might be color
blind or have this propensity. And so she had me tested at you
know, one of the eye doctors with looking at the, the those little
bubble charts with colors that you may remember having taken at some point.
>> Sure and for anybody who may not be familiar with
those. What, can, can you describe that bubble chart a little more?
>> Sure it's, a basically a lot of little dots and those dots typically show
some sort of a picture or character or
letter. that a red green colored blind person
may not be able to pick out the particular
picture or letter that everybody else. You know, what
it pops out. So for instance, back to my
yellow orange analogy. you know you may have two
different shades of orange in there that to you
look really obviously different and to me look actually
about the same. So I'm not seeing that letter
that's popping out of the picture and you are.
>> Mm-hm.
>> There are actually other versions that go the other way.
Where you know it looks really stark to the red green
color blind person. And to the not red green color
blind person it actually looks you know, camouflage. and so
those tests you know make it pretty easy for the
eye doctor to pick out whose color blind and whose not.
>> So you were very young when, when
you, your I guess your mother found this out.
>> That's right.
>> And did it I mean was it a? Did it cause any issue? I
mean it was like okay, we knew this was a possibility and now what kind of,
if anything, was there to do at that point?
>> Not really much. you know, as I say her brother
and uncle had had it and so she was sort of
aware of it. And you know it, it's useful to know
that you see the world in different colors than everybody else.
>>
[LAUGH]
>> Just so you can be prepared and obviously that's not that I'm
just aware of today, too. So that I don't say, you know, this is
definitely purple to people if they if I realize, I go oh my gosh
it might actually be blue and you know others are saying it is blue.
>> Nice, it does bring that interesting perspective though, that, the fact
that you put it in that context. You know, you don't want to speak
with certainty that this is this color because you're like it may not
be right. But what is quote unquote right is just what the majority
of other people see. I mean, you could argue
that if more people had solved the spectrum as
a red-green color blind person the way we describe
that, you know. Then that would be purple I guess.
>> Agreed, agreed.
>>
[LAUGH]
so as you've grown up, and even know as an
adult. How does breaking color blindness breaking affects your daily
life? Do you have, what kind of special, if anything
sort of interactions you have to go through to accommodate?
>> You know not much when I close
shop, you know, online certainly helps these day because
the colors are all labelled. you know when
I go clothes shopping in a store. I'll often
ask the retail person just a sanity check. What color is this? If it's blue I'm
generally pretty sure I'm okay. Or black or
things like that. but if I'm getting something that's
in the green spectrum. You know I'll want
a sanity check that it's what I think it
is and it's not some version of orange.
Or something that people are going to comment on.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So that's one way, you know, another way is just
periodically things that look camouflaged to me won't be camouflaged to
other people. So for instance, you know, my kids the other day were playing with
an orange ball in the yard. And to me when they it dropped in the grass
it was almost camouflaged in the grass. And they new, they thought that was the
funniest thing in the world, because to them
it's orange just totally popping off the lawn.
>> Right, right. So, you'd actually have to
sort of keep track of where it is to.
>> A little bit. You know, again, if it's
right by me, of course, I could see it, but
[INAUDIBLE].
>> I'm going to back up a little bit and talk
about generalities. I mean, just as you as Jeff Donaker,
what are the what are your kind of hobbies? What
kind of things do you do for fun in general?
>> Well, I've got two young kids who are pretty into sports at this point.
And you know certainly helping them with
school and their sports they like to play
baseball and soccer. And just generally run
around like little boys do. So other than
work, what I tend to with my spare time is kind of hang out with my family.
And run around playing sports with them and doing things like that.
>> Yeah, I've heard that kids can be
a full-time job but a full-time play job too.
>> Indeed, it's a little of both. A labor of love.
>> were you did you have to get your your, you said you have two sons?
>> Yeah.
>> Did you ,were you worried
about having, them having red-green color blindness
too, at all? We didn't really think about it. I had always assumed based
on our family history that had come through my mom's side of the family. And, as
a result given my wife doesn't have any
history of color blindness on her side of the
family. We sort of assumed that our kids
weren't, would not be colorblind. And then they haven't
been. they haven't you know indicated any color
blindness and so we haven't bothered to follow up.
>> Sure, you know we've talked about a lot of
other traits in our course like lactose intolerance. Some some traits
that are just sort of, you know, every day
but people may interact with differently. Some people assume, you
know everyone is may be lactose tolerant or that
everyone can see you know all colors the way they
do in certain ways. how have, do people in
general, friends, strangers respond to anybody, news of someone being.
Hey guys can you wait a second I'm not sure
about this. How do people respond to this particular trait
of red-green color blindness.
>> I would say that, you know, probably about half
of people that I interact with already know somebody closely who
is red-green colorblind. So it's no news to them and they'll
just say, oh yeah, my brother is also or something of
that nature. And then the other half, it's like a
great party trick. So the first time they hear that you're
red-green color blind, what they want to do is walk around the
room going, what color's this? What color's this? What color's this?
[LAUGH].
You know which is fun for about 30 seconds
Then you're kind of ready to move on
but that's been my general. Experience over the years.
>> Yeah, I can imagine that's good for
[LAUGH]
like the first two times.
>> Right.
>>
[LAUGH]
>> You actually, one thing that occurred to me in terms of day-to-day life
is, sometimes LCD projectors and things of
that nature. The reds in those don't show
up very well. And so that's kind of another way in, you know, kind of
modern life, where sometimes. Things that are
real obvious to the other people in the
[INAUDIBLE]
kind of like, well, I don't see that
at all because of the particular hues that were
[INAUDIBLE].
>> It's interesting you say that, I am from a research
science background. And there's a particular kind of experiment for lack
of a better word, called a microarray that you can do.
And when you get the results back, they color code all
of the results and it's a spectrum from red to green
and yellow. It goes from like red to yellow to black
to yellow to green. And it's supposed to give you, it's
essentially a heat map and of some of sorts. And there was
eventually, finally you know, people spoke up who
were regular color blind. And said, guys change
we please change this to like blue yellow so that we can look at the data too?
>> Yeah, that's right. If you're ever doing those kind
of charts, if you can make the red blue or the
green blue or something. Like that, just pick one of
them so it doesn't go from green to yellow to red.
>> Exactly. Have you ever not been able to participate
in something or anything because of the color blindness or anything
like that. Or have you pretty much always been able to find some work
around if it was an issue, you could you know it was always doable?
>> Yeah, I mean as a general statement it's
really never been a big deal. I certainly remember
a couple times as a kid where I felt a little left out or picked on during art
projects at school. Where you know, inevitably I'd pick
the wrong color. You were supposed to do something
that was brown and I picked green or something
of that nature and the other kids would tease me.
You know I really remember maybe two
or three instances. But you certainly work around
it and somebody points you to the right color and you keep moving. So never been
a big deal by any means but yeah, there's certainly a little bit of that. Like
you and me we're a little bit different
from the way everybody else is seeing it.
>> Sure. in that same vein, I mean, it
seems like a follow-up question that I've asked lots
of different people about their various traits. Would you
want to change this about yourself or would you not?
you know, that's an interesting questions. I think now in my life, no, I
don't think I'd bother. I guess if I had it all to do over in
the spirit of what you're, you guys are talking about out. Sure, yeah, I'd
probably rather see the world in the
same color hues and that everybody else does.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Just, you know, kind of one more thing. Makes things a little bit easier.
>> Mm-hm. Are there any advantages to seeing colors differently?
>> yeah, the main one
at this point is really the party trick that we talked about.
>> [laughs]
>> but.
>> Making, making friends quickly.
>> Right, right. But ostensibly in and earlier time. because
there are some forms of camouflage that look like camouflage to, you know, the
normal folk but don't to me, extensively during World War II. And
kind of the previous era, red-green color blind people could be pilots because
they could actually spot the camouflage from, you know, the army
troops much more easily than you know a typical person's eyesight
could. So that's a legend that I've heard in the years.
never been relevant in my life. You know I guess another
funny way in which it shows up for me is things
like it's very easy for me to take the Christmas tree
lights on and off the tree every year. Because the wires
actually really pop out for me and to everybody else ostensibly
they're totally blended in with the tree.
>> Oh yeah, it's totally true, I normally have trouble
unlike searching the branch trying to like just yank and pull.
>> Happy to come over to your place.
>>
[LAUGH].
I appreciate the offer I might take you up on that.
so we will finish up here. I want to ask you one
more question, if like if someone is watching this. And you
know, there are like oh, you know, I wonder if I
am color blind. Or maybe someone's recently found out they are,
someone they know is. What advice would you give to somebody
who may have recently find out that, you know, they are
red green color blind? And of course there are other kinds
of color blindness too. what advice would you give to them?
>>
you know, I guess, first point would simply be,
it's not that big a deal. So you know
roll with it and enjoy the fact that you're
seeing the world in a slightly different color hue
than everybody else is. and then the other one
would be yeah, when your picking clothes. Ask a
friend who there who knows or a sales associate
at the store just so you know what you're buying.
>>
[LAUGH]
Sure well, thanks Geoff for joining us.
>> Thanks Mat and good luck to everybody out there